[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right morning everybody what is
going on
welcome to the stream um if you guys can
hear me if you can see me give me a
thumbs up
welcome welcome um it's good to be back
on another saturday doing another 3d
live stream for you all
we do these every week you know most of
you guys are regulars you all know this
but if you're coming from
corridor welcome to the channel good to
see you guys thanks for watching the vfx
arts react episode
um yeah so every week you know we do 3d
live streams here and
we work on our passions together which
in this case is 3d modeling 3d texturing
just making stuff generally in 3d making
stuff look cool and
following those passions every single
week so saturday morning cartoons
um was one of my favorite things as a
kid growing up
and now it's saturday morning vfx
welcome everybody thanks for hopping in
so um
yeah what the heck is going on i'm
running a a render contest right now
it's called dynamic machines and i'm
challenging you i'm challenging
literally everyone
who can open a 3d program to join me
and create the coolest 3d contraption
you can possibly create
if you want to learn more about how to
get started
on this on this collaborative challenge
there's a link down below going to an
announcement stream or an announcement
video rather
where i talk about everything and like
you know how to
you know how to get started and what you
guys need to know because there's the
very specific rules you got to follow
there's a
there's a project file you got to
download which i'll show you here in
just a moment
um and yeah at the end of it basically
i'm going to combine everything together
into
one uh seamless looking contraption
from the community it's going to be
incredible i'm so excited i can't wait
to put that video out um so this is the
second to last weekend next weekend july
31st
is the last saturday um to work on this
i technically have not started my
submission yet i've done two
on the past two streams but those are
just to kind of get you guys an example
i'm actually going to start my official
submission today so if you hadn't
started yet don't worry you're not
behind
because i'm right there with you um what
else what else
for those of you who have finished your
submissions or are getting close
um there is a submission link it
actually is announced
today this is the first time i've
announced it so the link it's in the
description
leads you to a submission page make sure
you follow that page correctly because
you can only submit once there's so many
submissions i only got so much google
google points all right i can only hold
so much so much storage
so you can only upload once make sure
it's your final render if you submit a
work in progress
i'm taking that as your final render so
make sure you follow that page
closely the link is in the description
so let me let me
show you guys what we're going to be
doing today on the live stream i'm going
to get as far
as i can um
yo thank you for the super chat uh i
have a similar beard to vsauce michael
well
i don't know if that's a compliment or
just a you know
you know i do what i can i do what i can
appreciate yeah
let's uh let's figure out what we can do
here on the stream what the goal is so
let me
switch over for y'all
this is what i'm gonna make
i'm not gonna finish it on the stream
but i'm gonna get as far as i can
within a reasonable reasonable amount of
time
this is a photograph by one of my
favorite photographers
joe nishizawa he's a japanese
photographer
who lives in japan and he takes pictures
of some of the coolest
things you ever seen um places you would
never
really be able to visit he gets access
to
um laboratories and different like
engineering facilities and he's
currently
photographing the uh the deconstruction
of the fukushima power plant so this
dude is amazing
joe nishizawa he's on instagram
he's an absolutely incredible
photographer so i'm going to be
recreating this in 3d
this is going to be a lot of pipes and
wires
and basic geometric shapes here but it's
just a lot of detail
a lot of detail so like i said i'm not
going to finish this on the stream here
but i'm going to get as far as i can
once i can build out something similar
to this vibe i'm going to
get our ball hooked up and guide it down
this contraption
so the first goal is to just get this
look going
and then i'll worry about how the ball
is going to navigate through all of
these pieces
um and i'm going to show you a couple
different websites
that i'm using to source uh
different pieces like this one of them
is a free website it's really cool i
can't wait to show you all
um i'm doing this in cinema 4d i know a
lot of you guys use blender it's a free
program
but whatever you're using the whole
point is
to you know get inspired and focus on
your passion right so it doesn't matter
what program you're using it doesn't
matter
what tools you have access to the point
is just to
get inspired and like you don't have to
do exactly what i'm doing i know all of
you are probably working on your
submissions too
dysk music what's up from sydney
australia yo
one day i'll visit one day i'll come
down there i love traveling
and i'm excited for things to open up
hopefully within the next
i don't know a few months a year or so
i'm ready to travel again
um before we jump in i think that's it
um
in uh not in honor of but
in conjunction with the announcement of
the
submission link for uh the dynamic
machines challenge
we actually got a sponsor today uh it's
concierge render they are our render
farm
and i'm gonna play you guys just like a
quick minute little thing to show you
what they are who they are
and how you can submit your your
essentially your scenes to their site
through their render farm be able to
uh essentially render your stuff through
their service
it's very cheap they got a nice deal for
you all and i think it would be helpful
for you guys if you
want to use a render farm to complete
your submissions so
back in about a minute and a half i'll
see you guys soon so as we approach the
august 1st deadline for the dynamic
machines render challenge
concierge render is stepping up to
sponsor this stream
and hook all of you up with a really
nice deal
concierge render is a render farm
service that takes the stress of
rendering your complex 3d scenes
off your plate and onto their servers
stacked with enough gpus and ram
to run a small country rendering your
final scene couldn't be easier with
their simple
setup all you need to do is upload your
project file through the file manager
and launch the render select your
program
render engine and render type double
check your frames and resolution
and select the hardware you'd like to
use for the job
they even have some handy upload
instructions for any first timers
then just hit render watch the frames
roll in it's actually super satisfying
to watch
concierge render supports blender's
cycles and ev engines
as well as cinema 4d's physical and
redshift renderers
and has a legit customer service chat
ready to help you
at any moment along the way and fans of
the channel click the link below
to receive ten dollars in bonus credits
for your first
ten dollar purchase they're also
throwing in another five bucks
if you can verify your phone number
that's plenty of render hours to render
your dynamic
machine submissions and more by august
1st
so click the link in the description to
get your account set up right now
heck yeah they're actually really cool
service uh thanks for your time
everybody thanks for watching it uh
i wanted to do something with them
because i felt like it really would help
you i
really try and choose all of these
brands that sponsor these streams and
these videos
that best support what we're all trying
to do together so
um i really take a lot of a pride in
hand selecting all of these
i don't want to just serve you guys ads
that don't make sense so this one
is a good one because we're all trying
to render some stuff for this challenge
by august 1st so
check it out they got if you spend 10
bucks they'll give you an extra 10 bucks
if you verify your phone number like you
heard you get an extra five bucks so
that's plenty of time
plenty of render tokens to uh to render
your submissions so
uh one of y'alls one of you guys asked
if you wanted to see the uh
submission or the art that i did last
week so let me play that for you real
quick
and then we're gonna hop into it let me
just open it up here on my uh
let me try and find this thing let's see
here let's navigate to it i made like an
ice machine
you kind of saw it there in the ad um
but let's see
one of the art vfx render here we go
all right so this little ice ice box
this was just a
you know i did this on the last stream
completed the whole thing minus the
render itself
um but it was really fun i learned a lot
while doing it uh we all learned a lot
together
um and i think it turned out pretty cool
like a fun little slide
an ice maker an ice machine um i
if i wanted this to be my final
submission i'd probably do a lot more to
the texturing and grunge it up i'd
you know switch up some stuff i'd add a
lot more detail but this was just an
example to give you guys a really
you know just a cool idea of what we're
trying to create here you can see how it
all loops together
and each one of these little boxes will
be a different submission from y'all
so that's what we doing and today
i'm making this
god this is gonna be this is gonna be
ridiculous this is so detailed
oh boy oh man thank you all for the
super chats i really appreciate you
shout outs from uh melbourne australia
and frost tk oe
y'all are great thank you so much for
the super chats it's very helpful
but let's let's start creating um i'm
gonna show you a couple of the things
that i'm gonna use
to get this going so right here we have
our template scene
you can download it on the pny landing
page just click the link to the uh
dynamic machines announcement video from
there
you'll you can follow along completely
everything's in the description of that
video
there's just a good number of rules so
you want to make sure you follow them
pretty closely
technically you got to make sure
technically you're all
set up because you know it'd be really
easy to screw this up and have your
puzzle piece essentially not fit the big
puzzle
you got to have your puzzle piece fit
the big puzzle and as long as you follow
the rules
uh you'll be all right evolver
interactive shout outs man
good to see you again as always uh he's
a regular
he loves helping out the community he's
doing cool stuff always appreciate the
uh the support man
shout outs brother
awesome awesome oh we got we got mr clay
too up in here he won second place for
the alternate realities challenge
i'll be seeing you at camp mograph
pretty sweet
and there's actually a nice little
coincidence there martin thanks for the
five
uh five pounds actually very nice
heck yeah uh how's it going it's going
well man it's going very well
streaming is always a little stressful i
want to feel like i can offer as much
value as possible to you guys and have
it be as entertaining
and whole and complete as possible
but there's just no way we're gonna
finish this on the stream so we're gonna
get as far as we can and just help you
all out as much as possible
but this will be my official submission
i'm starting it now
so if y'all are just doing the same
don't worry it's not too late
all right let's see we got almost got
900 people up in here
heck yeah all right
so how am i going to build this
ridiculous
contraption am i going to model all this
by hand probably not
i'll model some of it by hand but not
all of it a lot of it
can be sourced and kit bashed from a
couple different packs let me show y'all
so the first one is actually really cool
it's a free one and this is not a
sponsor or anything this is just a
really cool resource so there's this
site called mcmaster car and they sell a
bunch of like machined parts and whatnot
and not all the parts but a lot of the
parts
actually have cad models that come along
with them so let me show you how this
works if you go to the main page
mcmastercar.com
you can find like a screw and a bolt you
know and they have every possible thing
it's ridiculous
let's grab a standard socket head screw
or something
maybe this one here and if you click on
the model number
you actually get by product details the
cad file
right here and for c4d the the
iges file works the best i tested them
all
um iges so i'm gonna
download that to my desktop
and drag and drop it into c4d
you know bam
and you got a screw ready to use it
comes in a bunch of pieces so i'll just
control
a it right click and we'll
connect objects plus delete now it's a
whole object and because a lot of the
parts are kind of overlapping we have a
lot of overlapping
points i'm just going to select all the
points hit zero
do a box selection and you can see up in
in the top left
points we have 3600 points roughly but
if i if i optimize this
you can right click and hit optimize
down here or
always learn your shortcuts you owe bam
you can see that went
from 3600 points to
2900 points so it just got rid of any
duplicate points that are on top of each
other if you're not seeing this
little dialog box up here you can hit
alt v
go to hud and you can check
the where are you filter yeah it's under
filter
i no it's not where is it view hud i
think i had it right the first time
where the heck is it camera distance
selected points there we go selected
points
selected edges selected polygons
selected and gone it's also a good way
to know what your fps is
so let's see where are you frames per
second you can check that and
see how your performance is doing you
know lots of good stuff to
check on here and and reference as you
work
so that's just a quick way i'm grab i'll
be grabbing a bunch of parts
for this ridiculous super detailed
reference um otherwise you know you can
use like cg cgtrader.com there's a bunch
of
like if you type in tech parts kit bash
or something like that
there's a bunch of different packs you
can use um and a lot of you probably
know
about bam the man himself
bolgarov is a super incredible
3d modeler an artist he puts together
all these kit bashing tools so
we can use a lot of this to create
that super detailed reference that we'll
be doing on the stream today so i'm
using these parts i'm using the mcmaster
car parts and i'll be
modeling some stuff that needs to be
hand modeled
to achieve this look so
where the heck do we even start this is
ridiculous
right it's a whole lot of stuff
um maybe we can start with the outer
edges
where all these pipes are running down
the back
we can just start with pipes like
literally i could spend this whole
stream just doing pipes
um we'll see where it takes us
uh what's the best way to do some pipes
here
so types we might be able to make
ourself let me get back to the chat see
how y'all doing
oliver yo oliver thank you for the super
chat recently came back to your channel
after you left corridor saw carbon
warfare so many years ago
inspired to learn to create photo
realistic renders from absolutely no
experience wish me luck dude
i wish you luck i have a stream or two
a ways back the thumbnail is like a
doorknob
um i recreate a doorknob i also recreate
a teapot
photo reel recreation i take a picture
and i recreate the whole
thing in a few hours and get a final
result on the stream so
those are two good ones for you to
follow i go over everything texturing
modeling lighting
matching up your photo your reference
photo to what you're actually creating
and yeah it'd be a really good resource
for you but yeah man
it's it's really fun i love 3d
you know you're only limited by two
things
your technical ability and what you can
imagine
so that's pretty powerful if you're good
enough in 3d
you can create anything you want
anything you can imagine and you're only
limited by your imagination
and that's huge that's why i love it
martin i see you man
thanks for the extra five uh five pounds
appreciate it
all right
first vault dweller yo yo man thanks for
the kind words i appreciate it
wait welcome everybody welcome from
corridor we're at 8.93
almost at 900. let's see if we can get
recreating this
this thing here let me switch over to my
stream
view and i'll just dock this right up in
here
or quick reference
all right let's let's get uh
so many things we can go over so many
things we can go over lighting
modeling texturing um but i'm just gonna
work on this and just
kind of shout it out as we go i guess
the first thing
i'll do
let's see if we can't get some lighting
that looks kind of nice
and a background on this box
set the set the playing field you know
so i'll make sure this is all saved
you don't want your stuff to crash on
you make sure you're saving iterations
too that means like a v1 a v2 of e3
don't save over the same file all the
time
mission 3 v1 yep we're good for now
since we haven't done anything
let's render this and let's
scale it down here so we can see what's
going on
i'll make this a little bigger for y'all
all right so let's see if we can put
this
nvidia quadro rtx a6000 to the test
48 gigabytes of vram let's see if we can
max it out with this image right here
oh goodness all right
so let's uh let's grab an hdri i
love grayscale gorilla they have the
best assets and stuff
for c4d someone make an octane sky
and i will add an hdri link plus
tag i'll click my environment tag and
drag the
texture dialog into
this hdri tag here we can open their
library and choose
from any number of amazing hdris it's
integrated straight into c4d
they are the best we want something a
little front lit it looks like uh
let's see here i guess we can grab
any one of these
i think one of them is tinted like blue
and
yeah this one right here
and we can orbit this with the
environment tag so that the orange is
facing front
just like that i'd say
and we can bring the power down to 0.5
or we can also do that from the camera
if i right click the camera let's give
it an octane camera tag
go to the camera imager tab will enable
that
and i usually like to switch over to
linear
change my gamma to 2.2 and then let's
crank up the highlight compression so we
save those highlights
you can bring down the exposure just a
little bit
and let's give this a metal texture so
same deal grayscale gorilla plus library
uh we'll hit up their textures materials
rather
tech products and let's just try out a
few different
ones let's see
something
hmm what do we want to do how many
options sandblasted aluminum
does that look like
okay maybe something a little brighter
steel connector perhaps
i'm just drag and drop on this thing
steel connector actually that's
that's pretty close you know like the
color
the color temperature can be different
but i'm not trying to go exact on it i
just want to get something to set us up
with
and it looks like we need a few more
samples on this thing don't we
i'll go to my octane camera settings or
octane settings rather and
i'll just hit it at a thousand
and the texture is looking a little a
little large
but it doesn't it doesn't quite matter
at this point we'll just have this to
block things out with it's feeling
really cool
so i'm gonna get up in here load it with
some pipes
we got these pipes on the side
that we can do that run from top to
bottom
we got some smaller pipes going along
the back like this is absolutely absurd
we can also block out our modules too
and our different islands of of detail
so we got like
essentially we'll block it out right
we'll block this out and then we'll add
pipes leading to these little pieces
and we can always change it later too so
we can move these pipes around move the
pieces around
based on how we want the ball to fall
and go through this contraption so i'm
going to essentially turn this
into a contraption
so
we can pause the render we don't really
need it now
awesome all right
we got ronin in the chat one of our mods
shout outs ronin
super good dude thanks for holding it
down
we might have a couple others we might
have visual up in here somewhere as well
um
but all right let's see how do we want
to proceed
save our stuff figure out what kind of
pipes we want let's let's maybe block it
out so i'm just going to use some cubes
hit t for scale
and how this down
n b turn on your uh
change your shading mode so you go to
display change all these displays makes
it a little easier to see
and let's hop out of the camera
and block out some of these modules
now maybe something
this and like this i have a few
different pieces like this blue piece
circular piece up here the circular
piece down here
and i'm not again not trying to get this
exact
but more of just a a general
look and feel and this might be even
going a little too
far but it might help us out just so we
can connect some pipes to something
make a cylinder and these are all just
placeholders
90 degrees this way let's make it
a little flatter here that's perfect
get this up and
back
nice ctrl drag to duplicate
get that down there and we got some side
pipes we want to work in so let's make a
new cylinder
hit t for scale again
and let's bring this diameter down the
radius rather
push this back into the box just a bit
yeah we have a bunch of different pipes
running through this thing
little drag over here perhaps
and maybe we build out a pipe
and we use that as like our main pipe so
it looks like
these pipes on the left and right are
fairly similar
and we can get more detailed as we go
but i think a general
the best approach for this
because technically we could do this one
of two ways we could build the
contraption
first and then build the environment
around
the contraption and i'm kind of
imagining this
style as both the contraption and the
environment around the contraption
but we can't really do anything
until
how do i want to phrase this
i'm going into this with half
knowing what i'm doing and half not
knowing what i'm doing
the knowing part is i want it to look
like this the not knowing is
specifically how i want the ball to go
through this contraption
right so
i know i need to build pieces like this
i could use this
to you know recreate these pieces
perfectly i also don't i could i could
you know eyeball it and just get
different parts and stuff
and source different parts but then it's
a question of where do i
put those parts if for example we're not
doing it exactly like this
so the parts need to be sourced that's a
guarantee that needs to happen
and then deciding how those parts
work with each other
is is probably the next step
so maybe what we do is we build out the
big pieces for example if i were to
break this
down let me let me open up photoshop for
y'all real quick
and show you what i'm thinking visualize
what i'm thinking here
because i think this will be helpful for
everybody
so let's see here
if we can determine what the
big general pieces are
then we can figure out how these pieces
are tied together
with detail because like check this out
basically what we have here are
i'm seeing this piece you know
this looks like the same piece but
flipped
i'm seeing this piece right here
i'm seeing these two pieces
those are kind of the main pieces
that's what i'm seeing as the large
detail pieces
obviously we have this pipe that's
connecting things
and this is like i'd say a medium detail
piece
right up in here
but as far as the main detail goes i'm
looking at like
four to five different modules
and these modules are
kind of what all these other pieces
are looking towards so all i'm imagining
this right so all of these
all include this as well right this
piece here
and is there anything else we can
include um
maybe this one down here right so these
are like the main
the main points of this entire art
of this scene and everything else
literally everything else is
like if i were to gray this out for you
and just visualize this for a moment
let's let's do this right um
let us
let me grab
make a mask on this
and if we paint with a black brush
we'll essentially erase this right
so everything that i'm not erasing is
just
filler
and is is literally just detail right
i don't know if that's necessary i i
don't i think that stuff can come later
you know what i mean it wouldn't make
sense to focus on
that ancillary stuff first i think it
makes
the most sense to focus only on
these main pieces first and foremost
right here let me grab a
g for the paint bucket oh it's gradient
right now bam
i'll get like a dark gray on this or
something boom
like these kind of pieces are the main
ones that i'll probably want to start
with building out
these main modules and then like
the smaller detail on these will be how
the ball actually goes through our scene
and how the ball interacts with these
pieces here
right and then once you have the
contraption working and it's working
properly
then i'll come back and just worry about
you know everything else all the other
stuff in the background
so i think that's what i'll focus on
today on the stream
is just knocking out these main modules
and we'll get as far as we can uh we got
some super shouts
some super shots i like that um
let's see would it be cheating to
project the picture on
to the shape and cut out the pieces you
want to extend no that's the ian hubert
style
i'd say go for it absolutely
um what if the large shiny circles had a
ball cut out
and caught the ball spun around just
enough to drop the ball out yup totally
imagining something like that
absolutely and brian ash yo
huge huge thanks for that super chat
that is very kind of you
thank you so much um my oh
interesting my uh camera is
is dead let me fix that for y'all real
quick
you know what happens having a stream
without any technical difficulties
is a miracle so it
you know it happens it happens
but back to let's see back to brian
so uh what you and corder do in the
world of vfx inspire me to get into the
field myself
awesome heck yeah i have no experience
and i really don't know where to start
but i am very quick learner what would
you recommend i start with
yo great question okay so
um blender is free i'm using cinema 4d
it is a paid program but i think if
you're a student it's free
so i've heard um c4d
and blender are like the main the main
ones really right now
um you have programs like maya and 3ds
max and
unreal engine you can get an unreal
engine but that's deep
but if you want to get in the blender i
would highly suggest um
blender guru has you know every tutorial
ever for blender getting started in
blender the donut tutorial it's
infamous um ian hubert is also another
really amazing blender artist to follow
um
those are the two that i can guarantee
speak to i does default cube
use blender i think so that'll be a good
one
um
and that's how that's really how you
learn um if you want to learn c4d
personally the way i learned was from uh
david ariev through his octane tutorials
his c40 octane tutorials
i learned through uh grayscale gorilla
that's like the main one
and i learned through eye design i like
your eyeball
i design uh ej right so i learned from
those three
for c4d stuff and a number of other you
know
not random but like uh different people
but those are the main ones
and i just follow the tutorials that you
love they're really fun that inspire you
and make you want to make more stuff
um and join the join this challenge
challenge yourself learn blender it's
free you can get it like right now
um and have a good time
no no nay is suffering from creative
block that is totally a thing
um absolutely happens
and yeah let's see what what can we say
about creative block
so getting away
from the creative thing is a good thing
sometimes if you're stuck and you just
find that you're just trying over and
over
and nothing's coming to you walk away
take a break
go on a walk that's the first thing i'll
do is i'll go on a walk
or really just work out do something
active go outside
um and get away from the creative
process for as long as you need until
ideas start coming to you um
that's kind of like my first thing that
i'll do if i'm stuck on something
other than that yeah i say just go like
hang out with friends
watch movies do something other than
what you're trying to do and the
inspiration will come
in time it will come maybe in the shower
perhaps
um but yeah you can't have ideas flowing
all times
i also have art books that's what i i
get a lot of my inspiration from art
books and music so right now
i'm listening to my ambient playlist on
spotify it's like linked in one of the
some of the earlier streams i don't have
a link right now but um
yeah i listen to ambit music i listen to
music that inspires me to create stuff
i got art books in the closet back here
the
picture that i am trying to you know
roughly recreate is from one of those
art books
and i flip through that and i'll just
get filled with ideas like this is the
coolest thing ever you know i love
playing video games too that's a great
way for me to get inspired watch movies
so yeah yeah
best of luck to you let's get back to it
all right so we decided we want to make
these pieces here
and i'll generally recreate these pieces
as i see them
here on the page so
let me screenshot this
and in fact i don't even need those
either
and i'll drop this up in here
all right
let's see if we can't kit bash any of
these pieces as a
quick starting method here um i have
those vitali bolgarov
kit bash pieces here and what i don't
want is for
this to be a vitaly bolgarov hit bash
piece i don't want that to be a thing um
mainly because his stuff is so
well used on the internet and so
recognizable at this point i just
i wanted to feel a bit more unique than
that you know
so i'll use the pieces sparingly
or at least in a way that you know
actually it doesn't look like uh the kit
bash
of the totally bulgarov kit bash demo
you know what i mean
let's start with this main piece right
here
so to me that just looks like a bunch of
cylinders and cubes
and we could probably spend an entire
stream
modeling this ourselves
let's see how far we get um
anything cylinder wise cylinders
cylinders so we have some stuff
here very techy
looking i want to go for something a bit
more plain
maybe we do build this out ourselves
maybe this is just me struggling
to 3d model again
it's a fairly simple piece to create up
here
but getting everything to mesh together
like this
and seem like one piece is
it will be interesting i think we maybe
we can use a metaball
situation or perhaps uh voxel
modeling to build this up and actually
have it feel like one seamless piece
um
because the perfectionist in me really
wants to make this one seamless piece
that way
you got your all your bevels and
everything and it just looks
super nice andre yo
thank you for the super chat very kind
of you much appreciated shout outs
awesome awesome
oh snap dan yo
my goodness thank you sir thank you very
much
very kind of you uh let's see what dan
oh god i keep bringing this up on axe
get this get this out
um dan okay so hey clint my current
contract requires me to work
11 7.
11 hours a day seven days a week is that
what that means but i've managed to
squeeze in a couple hours most nights
for the challenge
yes yes yes it's great to take some time
to do something more fun thank you for
showing
for throwing these together absolutely
man that is the whole point of this
channel
is to learn and grow together and be
inspired through that process
so i'm really glad that you're taking
that extra time to
focus on the stuff you love doing
it is very important gotta do what you
love
gotta do what you love
um so thank you thank you for the super
chat dan i appreciate it very much man
all right back to it
god
i'm alive all right here we go
um how do i want to do this do we want
to build it from
scratch it's more fun that way
let's do it rip
because it's going to take a minute all
right here we go
i'll start with a cylinder let's start
with the old
cylinder scale it down we'll worry about
how big all this stuff is later okay
and let's go ahead and bring the height
down
something like that
and that's about all we need to do
for this piece n b n b
n is in nancy b is in boy that's going
to bring up your
different shading mode here so you can
see the actual lines on this thing
segments zero rotational segments
32 is probably fine all right
and let's make this
editable
all right we can do this a bunch of
different ways i'll probably i'll spend
a few different ways
creating this
let's take this top piece out
and
i wonder if what does the matrix
extrude is that what we need
oh my goodness all right so how about we
don't
do it per piece
is it really the whole thing huh every
little piece just comes out like that
very interesting steps
eight steps hmm now we can probably do
this a little bit more
simply
let's go ahead and extrude this
uh just d and hit d i'll bring this up
to about there and let's give it like
eight subdivisions
cool and then what we can do is
hopefully with a
soft selection we can scale this down
i'll hit t for scale and if we scale
this right
i want it to scale like this like this
little ramp
so we can hit t for scale enable soft
selection
and let's see if we can't just take the
radius down to like 20 centimeters
so you see i'm where i'm getting at we
just need to invert
that
would it be circle
kind of would be circle huh
and i know there's probably better ways
to do this
like that's pretty close
something like that
and maybe we can take that radius
up to 20.
or maybe even 30 what does 30 do
you say beveling would be better i
wonder so let's do this version here
something like that and then we could
maybe before we do that just to compare
it
let's see we saw what that looked like
if we bevel it
ms
get that up there we'll go eight
subdivisions
and
let's see is there a shape on this
oh we can go profile user
and draw our own shape up here okay
maybe we'd get rid of these points
control click to make our own points
i wonder why it's popping out in the
middle like that
i want to go in
maybe it's because i need to actually
bring this down about there
and try and just get gradual swoop on
this now i don't know
why on earth it's doing this
yeah i have no idea
that's just linear interesting okay
there we go okay so if we go
negative on it i feel like
the only way to really get this shape is
to
all right so we're getting close
and i want to push this down a little
bit
about there yep
and then we can just bring everything
up so i'll hit
w we'll get our move tool and
let's go ahead and extend the move tool
20 centimeters linear
something like that perhaps so that took
quite a while i think you could probably
just do it manually by hand it'll be a
little bit faster
let's make some cuts in this thing so kl
line tool bam
bam right so we have a nice little cut
there
and then it looks like there's a cut up
top right up in here
and at the very top probably
here and here so these pieces
can be let's see ul is your loop
selection
we turn off soft selection drop that
down
we want these little cuts to be pretty
small
and we can hit ul in polygon mode
holding shift we'll grab all these
little pieces here i'm gonna hit d
we're gonna extrude
we don't need all the subdivisions clear
that out
peel that down and now we have these
little cuts
little rivets inside of this piece here
now i want to smooth this out we want to
bevel it so
let's uh let's throw a bevel modifier on
it i like using the bevel modifier i'm
going to select everything
or actually wait before let's run into
the problem before we do anything like
that just to show you what's happening
deathstroke got the brownies heck yeah
for brownie right now
um all right with the cylinder selected
hold shift
drop the bevel modifier on it and let's
just set it it looks weird right now
right that's because
things are all off because our offset
needs to be a little smaller
0.1 centimeter let's zoom in and see
what is actually happening 0.05
there we go
and then we'll give it like three
subdivisions so it's a bit rounded
right so we have a nice smooth surface
there
and maybe we can bring up
these bits here hit zero select these
points
and 0 brings up your rectangular
selection
the rectangle selection and that by
default cuts through
all the points in the back it selects
everything
we got a piece here we can uh
we can render this let's see
come on octane are we gonna crash
already
let me just copy this
into our scene
so notice notice here that the
when i pasted this in here
oh my goodness it pasted all that stuff
never mind i don't want that
i want to copy this
paste it in perfect
we can solo these two bits
try to render again
and if we drop one of them grayscale
gorilla textures on this thing
some sort of painted metal
there's something in here their tech
products kit is amazing
rubber cord metallic speaker
speaker suspension
interesting
i like plastic
it looks a little low poly
you could probably make a couple more
cuts in there
to even that out
oh that's super cool i love that that's
amazing
field connector
so it's just creating a bunch of pieces
and sourcing a whole bunch of pieces to
get this look so let me see if i can't
continue building this out and kit
bashing this stuff
nexib yo thank you for the super chat
thanks for these great contests so much
learning and inspiration pushes me to do
more 3d work in my spare time i'm sure
many others
man yes yes yes yes um
it's it really is a blast seeing your
guys's submissions coming in
over the next two weeks i guess
or a week it'd be one week yeah week and
a day
i can't wait i cannot wait to see what
y'all put together
so good and derek derek parra what's up
thank you for the super chat i missed
you much appreciated
thanks for joining me nice we're going
strong
880 of y'all up in here watching me fail
at 3d modeling
let's see
let's let's keep it let's keep it simple
let's go with a
out a simple block out and then we can
just get more detailed
as needed
so i'm just looking at this and
imagining what it's going to look like
this looks like it's pressed up against
the edge here
and maybe it looks something like this
and we can bevel this down
ms is your bevel tool
but we want to reset we want to go back
to
default settings what's the best way to
do this
um
zero subdivisions
zero tension yep and that gives us what
we want
something like that
a little bit of thickness on there and
we can make
all these detail cuts later let's just
get the block out first
all right it looks like there is
another set of
cuts here kl
maybe before i do that
we make these cuts bam down the center
i'll add one
i'll select both
and we can extrude let's see make
another
that's the best way to make it here
that back down
boom
add up just a little bit
and it looks like there's another cube
on this thing
i'm gonna go back in here later probably
not on the stream but i'm going to
detail all this out make sure it looks
good
my topology may not be the best but as
long as it looks good
that's what we want let's get this in
here
looks like that's right up in there oh
here's a tip for you
if i select this cylinder hold ctrl make
the cube
the cube will spawn right on
the cylinder so that way you know it's
centered
centered up perfectly and i'll scale
this down it looks like as much as
possible
so it comes right up to the edge
just like that nice and flush
there's a couple bolts on it but again
that's that's detail that we'll get
later we're doing a block out right now
um looks like there's some sort of like
cylinder piece that comes up and out so
let's utilize the sweep method let's
grab the spline pen
go into our side view
what is the correct side view on this
um would it technically be i guess it
would
be from here hide the camera so we can
see a little bit better
i'll make three three points one
two and three
and i'll make sure these are stacked
right on top of each other by hitting t
for scale holding shift and bringing
this all the way down to zero
you can see how you zero it out
they'll be stacked right on top of each
other and
technically this needs to come up
right to this one here so we can select
this spline
set it to zero on the y we'll select
this point and set it to zero on the y
as well
you know everything is nice and uniform
then what we can do is actually chamfer
this so i'm going to
select this point right click chamfer
and drag it out
somewhere somewhere like this it's
probably good
from here all we need to do is
make a circle spline
i'll scale it down with t
and it doesn't need to be in any certain
position it just needs to be the right
size it's a size reference
and we're going to take both the spline
and the circle spline
and put it into a sweep
object i don't know if it's a modifier
or a uh technically the
technical name sweep a sweep object yeah
i had it right
drop those in there switch the order
around
there you go all right it's taking up
the shape and the
circle determines how big that is
and we can adjust the spline
to you know do whatever we want
wonton yo thank you for the super chat
very
generous donation from you heck yeah
wonton says absolutely love the streams
and the vibe i'm a software engineer and
have zero interest or knowledge in doing
3d modeling myself but your streams are
the perfect thing to watch while i'm
working keep them coming
heck yeah that's great
i love it i love it um i'm glad that uh
i'm giving you a little bit of
entertainment
while you're working it means a lot
that's super cool thank you for the
super chat thanks for the support
shout outs to you let's keep blocking
this thing out
working from uh basically as a
as broad strokes as possible down to the
details i think i got a little too
detailed in the beginning there
all right what is next we have a giant
cube thing down here
so let's make a cube
hit t scale it down and we'll shape it
out
somewhere down here
it looks like the cube only goes as far
as that back bevel
but i could probably make it editable by
hitting c
let's grab this face here and
pull it back to this point we want to
round out the back of this thing
so the quickest way to do that
kl hold shift to snap to these points
we'll go right in the middle
we'll make probably five
cuts let's grab this point or this line
here
w right so that changes between
world and local orientation for this
specific uh situation that doesn't
really matter but let's go to the move
tool
enable soft selection set this to
circle perhaps pull it out just a little
bit
you can see how that gets us that
rounded shape in the back
nice and subtle and it looks
like there's some sort of plate coming
off the side of this thing so i'm a kl
cut right in there
grab these points we don't need soft
selection anymore let's disable that
and we'll grab all these bits right up
in here hit
d extrude them
and let's bevel out this top and bottom
ms
with a couple
we want a couple subdivisions three
perhaps
uh but we want it to be rounded uh fifty
percent
attention 50 100
i believe yes
right so it's just a general shape build
this thing out
brian what is up shout outs man thanks
for the super chat
awesome man so it says by the way i'm
working on an art project making
personalized pieces for each member of
the quarter crew
awesome i'd like to have each piece
include
their favorite quote can you help me
oh favorite quote
i think griffin griffins would have to
be got ya
gotcha definitely
you did he would like that nico
nico's favorite quote maybe something
along the lines of
the perfect camera um
[Music]
uh what else what else would nico say
yeah i think the per something something
along the lines of the perfect camera
sam would have to be
um like something about his soul being
as dark as night
um ren ren what would ren say
ren would eat whatever if you have a
camera around
ren will eat whatever you have on camera
it doesn't matter he will drink it he
will eat it
doesn't matter if it came from the
street the gutter or someone's armpit he
will eat it
um i don't know what that gets you i
don't know if that gets you
um daniel would have to be something
along
along the lines of like let's do a
segment
do you have time for a segment um nick
would have something to do with shrimp
um natalie would be like
i could probably solder that uh
jake something to do with an ad you know
today's sponsor is
something like that um and for me
i don't know man if you have to figure
that one out
who else
who else
that's about all i got for you i hope
that helps
i hope that helps
all right yes i was going to say look at
that neck
chris i was going to say that but i
didn't want to say it you said it thank
you
okay let's make some more pieces here
so it looks like we have
some sort of cube object
boom right up in the center back part of
this
thing what up son that's that's brett
though what up son is brett
that is all brett let's hold ctrl let's
make a disc ah we'll make a cylinder
we'll scale it down
hold press r holding shift to rotate 90
degrees let's
bring this down like this even smaller
that's a tiny little
piece hail it up
push it back
something like that it's got holes
cutting it that's detail work you know
that's a bunch of detail work
it's bugging me so i'm going to bevel
this thing
here just here ms
bevel done um
you know if you all saw my functional
filmmaking episode on
corridordigital.com
it's very similar um i made a film
camera
just like this i blocked it out and then
built it out did the detail from there
let's do another
cube
i'm gonna get this metal piece here
let's do another cube
here holding control with that cube
selected so we spawn it on the cube
i'm gonna flatten it up
and let's make it editable kl
edge mode for the loop cut bam
go ahead and scale this face down key
for scale
scale it down just like so
and let's go ahead and bring this
out point mode 0 for rectangle selection
grab all them points
looks like this comes out beyond this
bit
b for scale open it up
and let's go ahead and just grab
these two points
push them back
yeah just
like that okay so now what we need to do
is actually
actually redo this bit
here ui
will grow the selection
grab all these bits holding shift i'm
gonna delete them
and i'm going to bridge all these pieces
just to patch it up
let's get rid of the grid we don't need
it work plane
up by filter work plane
and i solo this by hitting this solo
button the s the gold
s orange s in
edge mode we'll hit n b or the bridge
tool
or sorry m b mandy
monkey membrane m
let's grab all these
patch it up and we just
want the subtlest of extrudes
but doesn't cut through all that you
know so hit d we'll extrude
that point and let's grab these bottom
points here
one ms
bevel and we'll just bevel that down
so now it's looking a little bit more
accurate now we need to make some cuts
in this metal piece here so
polygon mode
solo it and let's make some cuts
kl
ah interesting you see how it's
it's tapered we don't want that
what i'll do to fix that taper is
go into point mode hit zero grab one
side
scale for t hold shift bring those
points to zero
p for scale hold shift zero it out
and now it's normal and that happened
because
basically when you scale something right
here it scales it
uniformly on all axes
if you wanted to just scale it on one
axis so it's the x-axis that's
choking it like that right so we would
deselect the x
and scale and then it would scale
properly how we want it to scale
technically it's just a z or a y scale
um all right so when you make those cuts
right
so kl loop cut
hold shift we will make
a now what's the best way to do this
probably a knife tool huh line cut
hold shift bam bam
did that cut through everything no it
did not so we need to
make sure that does what we'll do for
that
is going to polygon mode
line cut and we want to
let's see
uncheck visible only
holding shift to keep those lines
straight and that should cut through
everything yep we want those two cuts
there
we'll grab them ul loop selection
and bring them down
then i want to make sure it's centered
so i'll eyeball it
probably right there centered
and we'll make a cut
out here as well and
finally a cut ooh i see what it's doing
okay we'll make a cut right here
and we'll take these two points
t for scale and drop them down
so that those bits are flat
and i'll select everything that needs to
be extruded
hit d and
we will extrude a little bit
and then we just want to select it looks
like based off of the reference
i just want to select these bits and
we'll extrude again
and finally actually i'll do it like
this i'll just grab this one
extrude that and i'll grab this one
and extrude that even more it looks like
this is being cut down
with a bevel one there one there
we'll hit ms
and zero subdivisions
something like that is
generally what that piece is looking
like to me
right so we have our
let's save this thing just realize yeah
we haven't even saved this thing
sub three module one
and let's just start color coding this
so that's gold we'll do this as like a
yellow
or diffuse
bam we have a silver
here and here
let me just do like a light gray for
that
and then we have a blue
like a faded gray gray blue
or everything else
and let's go ahead and copy all this
this will be
ctrl g and then alt g we'll call this
module one copy that
go into our submission paste it in
and let's scale it up or down rather
where are we
oh wow what
wait what
oh because we're in solo mode my
goodness it scared me for a second
module let's bring it up here
orient it properly 180
pop it right up in there and we have our
first block out
first little module piece right in there
the second module
we can make from this first one here
we don't really need this
this render here will pause that
the second one looks very similar and i
actually
just realized i'm missing a piece so
let's finish out this last piece here
for our block out
it's this like a gear looking piece
so for that
for that i'll probably do subdivision
surface
technique so
let's hide the camera
and let's make actually select
this cylinder right here yep
hold ctrl i'll make a
polygon yep get t for scale
scale it down and we're going to do
subdivision
surface on this so let's go ahead
and crunch it like so
and we want to keep everything as end
guns or not end guns we want to keep
everything as quads meaning
four sides
hold ctrl make new geometry
and we want to bring this kind of to the
back here
even there'll be one here
and another holding control
like so
this side looks like
kind of looking like a millennium falcon
and it looks like it's favoring the top
just a bit
maybe for that we bring it out up
and we make a cut right there
let's see what this does when we drop it
into a subdivision surface
which is this object right here and
that's going to smooth things out
really nicely it's not going to look low
poly it's actually going to look nice
so let's grab this bit
and we can solo it drop it into the
subdivision surface
what
that was weird okay
i held alt on the object itself
all right let's see
i mean that's pretty darn close for a
for a block out i'm just gonna give it
some thickness so
ctrl a to select it all hit d
and i'll show you what happens if we
just extrude it like this
and then apply the subdivision surface
you can see it's very rounded looks like
a frisbee we don't want that
we actually want to make some cuts here
to make things a bit more rigid so kl
loop cut we'll get a cut there we'll get
a cut there and that
sharpens it up pretty nicely
on the edges
and let's go ahead and
adjust this a little bit more
something like that
cube is there and this piece
about there
something like that
that's our module one
module 2 2 is very similar
we can control drag this down and it
looks
like it's a full flip on this
thing um like symmetry straight up
symmetry on this so what i'll
do is actually hit l
here let's make this about this point
we don't need we don't need it i guess
it'd be best for viewing
l bring it down here we want to drop
this into a symmetry
object so let's find
symmetry drop it in
and flip it on the appropriate
axis okay so it's way down there
but that's how we want it oriented all
right so i'm just gonna
hit c make it editable
and let's see if we can't bring out all
these pieces we want all of this
minus the octane sky
i'm out and be
oh it's the same object okay let's go
back i want to split these up into two
separate pieces quite simply
the best way to do this i mean we could
just
you know do this
drag symmetry so it's something like
that
very similar
hmm
yeah so i don't even know what this
machinery is
if i had to reference it in the book
i don't know where the book is at this
point but it's like some sort of um
i don't even know i couldn't even tell
you what this was
ah all right
so it looks like that's about exactly
what we want maybe minus this one little
dingling piece
but that feels pretty good to me
um this giant disc back here
is a very simple setup
that looks to me like a cylinder like we
currently have
we can crunch it down a little bit we
can get rid of those height segments
give it a bit more rotational segments
make it editable let's grab all of these
faces
and we want to extrude enter so that's
mw or you can right click
and select extrude enter bam
bring it in just a little bit
d for extrude and push it out just a
hair
because we want to have some bolts and
whatnot on the outside of that
and you can even bring that in a bit
more if you want
so we can just undo mw
bring it in d bam for extrude
give a little bit of something this we
can
delete and let's control drag this down
awesome
all right let's get rid of this box
it'd be sweet to have these like the
ball go
through this contraption
rolls over and it hits this like wheel
piece
that sends it around and a circle down
it bounces it hits this thing
it goes into this machine perhaps and
like
maybe this cube rotates a little bit
and it rotates with this piece maybe so
like these guys could be together and
this goes like
and it turns into like a balancing thing
where the ball lands on it
and no matter where the ball is it kind
of is kind of guiding it like this
and it pushes it down maybe into a tube
on this side which will be this next
module perhaps
and it goes through some sort of system
here maybe up through a pipe and down
next to this one and it hits this and
rolls
onto this wheel and leaves
the contraption and like we can have a
bunch of dials turning and whatnot
and electrical parts surging as it goes
through
and maybe something happens to the ball
perhaps i don't know
or maybe it's just simply a contraption
we could also
we could also have the ball like trigger
a bunch of other things perhaps but in
its simplest form like i think that
could be
pretty pretty sweet
psy sharon
welcome back good to see you again man
uh hey clint how are you good to see you
and excited for the result
me too i can't wait i love fighting off
way more than i can chew
i love a good challenge so for me this
is going to be an
incredible like just detail modeling
it's just boring work at a certain point
it's boring work i couldn't imagine how
it would be fun to watch me just sit
here
modeling a tiny module and have
point five percent of the whole thing
done you know it'd be
it'd be ridiculous um
but i'm really excited i'm really
excited for this thanks for the super
chat psy
good to see you man did i miss any i
don't think so now we good
how's everyone doing y'all having a good
time
we are hour and a half through the
stream right now
it is 12 19 in los angeles
and we're still going
good times listening to a little bit of
ryuchi sakamoto and alvinodo
up in the bone phones
i love their stuff they put out some
really great work
heck yeah rocking and rolling today
derek good to hear
very good to hear it's a good day it's
going to be a good day after the stream
i'm going to go
rock climbing outdoor rope climbing very
excited for that i've been doing it
probably once a week for the last three
months
um i'm a big big climbing fan i've
probably been climbing for three years
or so mostly like uh bouldering indoors
but
outdoor rock climbing with ropes that's
the way to go that's i found it
i found it oh
ren's son sent you my way very nice
got us to ren he's one of my best
friends what a good dude
vfx king my past self in a corridor ved
told me
told you that i was live shout outs to
my past self vfx king
shoutouts muhammad yo what's up man
thank you for the super chat
very cool first time tuning in to the
live stream hello from singapore
ah i want to go to singapore i hear it's
the cleanest
city in the world and i hear the
airport's pretty cool
and you got that sweet like skytree
thing
yeah yeah i want to stop by i love
traveling so much
so i get a lot of my inspiration from
traveling
taking pictures doing film photography
i really do enjoy it it's amazing
um i really appreciate y'all joining me
we got 700 people going strong
heck yeah
you're here from corridor shout outs
thanks for joining me on the stream
we're creating some cool 3d art today
very ambitious piece that i will not
finish on the stream but
you will see my final uh once these
submissions are due august 1st
for this dynamic machines challenge
those of you all who are just joining um
and participating in the dynamic dynamic
machines challenge
we got a submission link it's official
there's a submission link
you guys have one more week and one day
left to participate or to finish your
render
if you have no idea what i'm talking
about there's a link in the description
uh that leads you to my announcement
video for that for
the dynamic machines community render
challenge you can click that
you'll get everything you need to know
i'm doing my submission i'm just
starting my submission so
it's not too late i got a week left to
do this gonna be good
it's gonna be awesome
but yeah yeah it's good i'm excited
thanks for joining me all
i feel like i'm just rambling now let's
let's get back to work
all right so i'm gonna be releasing a
patreon
very soon if things go according to plan
it'll be exactly two weeks from now and
i will
i would love to have this project file
for you available
on that patreon um
with all these hand model pieces i'm
gonna try and hand model
all this stuff we'll see how much time i
have but i think a lot of these
different modules can be duplicated
like i'm seeing a lot of these plugs and
stuff can be duplicated
back here um
you know this bit here is the same piece
the pipes aren't that bad at all
and it's just basic cylinders and pieces
and dedication lots of time dedicated to
this
which is what it takes to make your
stuff look good you know
right are you allowed to do
two submissions um well technically
since you can only
upload one submission per your email you
might have to log into another email to
upload another submission
there's nothing wrong with uploading two
submissions um
i would rather you focus on one and make
it look legit
and split your work between two but if
you really want i mean this is my third
one technically so i can't stop you
make as many as you want but you can
only win once you can't win for second
and third place you know
samuel what's up man shout outs old
school video right there
that's a good one
all right so a lot of the nuts and bolts
i'm gonna get from mcmaster carr
i think that'll be a really smart way to
do it
and just make instances of that same uh
bolt let me just show you let me show
you exactly how i'm going to do it so
let's open up mcmaster carr
and we'll get this out of here
and let's find a
screw
let's see this will probably work
for us
now a hex screw is
probably the way to go
and we can get a combination of a few
different ones here but
just to show you an example of how i'm
going to do this let's grab a hex
screw oh there's a lot
and some of them actually have etchings
in them i like that a lot
very cool
let's grab this 8.8
and we'll go to the model number and
grab the cad file
iges download that
desktop it for now i don't advise you to
desktop everything
and if you hold shift you can actually
bring
this object into your current scene
rather than opening a new scene
i'll select all these bits that make up
this hex screw
right click connect objects plus delete
so it's just
one object hit s to snap
to the object
sweet this is it yeah
8.8 right there
looks amazing let me take this
and there's probably going to be
hundreds of screws
during this whole thing so let me delete
that
come up in here let's grab this screw
and see if we can't center it up
on this cylinder so
right here on the cylinder it'll drop it
right up in there
s to snap the viewport to the current
object you have selected let's get this
thing right
up in the center of this technically i
can use the uh
transfer tool but hey we just did it
there in two seconds
and then we'll bring this out about like
that
and what we're going to do is use a
cloner a radial cloner
to position this across
or around this entire thing so if you
hold alt
you can like what's the best way to
explain this okay so
here's what i want to do i'll show you
the the long way then i'll show you the
short way
so i'm going to make a cloner bam i
click the cloner and then i drag the
screw
into the cloner and it's going to clone
the screw
a bunch of times you can't see it right
now because it's really tiny
and all that but let me show you the
fast way the fast way is to select the
screw
hold alt and then click the cloner
and automatically the screw is a child
of the cloner object so we want it to
we want to clone this radially a radial
uh clone and the radius will set to like
10 centimeters that way you can see all
these screws
in a radial pattern and we'll set it to
like i don't know
30. but it's going in the wrong
orientation
so we want to change the plane that's
perfect
let's walk the radius in 9 centimeters
eight centimeters i actually use this
little slider here
bam just like that and then
one thing we can do to really add a lot
of randomness
to this is add a random effector so if
we
have the cloner selected we can hold
down this cloner object
and select the random effector and by
default
it's randomly positioning
all of those screws by 50 centimeters on
each axis
but we don't want that let's uncheck it
we'll check rotation
and we want to randomly rotate
these screws on the correct axis
it looks like the final one will be our
answer so we can just type in 1080
and it's going to align these screws in
different orientations so they all don't
look super uniform like this
a bit more handmade to it and if we hit
render after we save you can see
all right we have essentially we make a
new camera hop
into it bring down the exposure
a bunch of different screws on this
thing
and we'll drop a
yeah let's drop some textures onto this
if we get up in there you can see we
have a bunch of different screws
randomly oriented
for best results right
so that's how i'm going to be doing all
the screws on this thing it's going to
be
quite tedious but in the end it's gonna
look really cool
i can't wait
all right let's throw all of our
geometry minus the ball and the box
into its own folder
called geo
um all right we got a good question from
jazz
vfx asking what this glove is
so i get this question all the time
and it is yeah it's a drawing glove so i
use a tablet
i don't use a mouse and my wacom tablet
it's the intuos pro
uh tablet it's an amazing tablet
and without the glove i could either get
sweaty or just the oils
natural oils from my skin can
you know stop me from gliding over the
tablet
very easily so this glove just helps me
glide over the tablet tablet really
easily simply enough
you know that's it
um quaternious great name you're just
getting into film photography
heck yeah any tips yes don't be afraid
just don't be afraid um grab some
portrait 400
35 millimeter throw it in your camera
take some shots
get it exposed at a place and see what
happens all right
don't worry about ruining your photos um
try and
find a if you have a camera with a
built-in light meter that's great
or one thing you can do is actually take
your like dslr
if you have one and use the settings
from your dslr
and transfer them over to your film
camera so referencing the digital
where you can actually see your your
tweaks and moving them over to the film
camera
have fun with it it's a blast once you
get into it just mess with more
film stocks and everything and then
eventually you can try
developing yourself but that's much
later just have fun shooting don't worry
about ruining any photos it'll be all
right
back to it
timnay timmy builton thanks for the
super chat
much appreciated no message necessary
just
just a straight up uh support i really i
really appreciate that
we got visual in the house one of the
mods
very powerful very powerful man
up here moderating the server doing big
things
um all right
moving on so
detailed detail detail lots of lots of
detail
maybe what we'll do is uh
detail out a piece
to show you all what the full detail
version will look like and what needs to
be done every single time so
maybe like
this piece up here i don't know what
should we detail
there's a lot we can do
all these wires
plugs and stuff all this stuff can be
duplicated very
easily use instances
when you duplicate stuff save on vram
what would be a fun piece we could make
like really this is all very basic stuff
it's just
placing it all which is killer
i think this is the most complicated
piece this
one blue piece right here is
ridiculously complicated
to get as one piece um
how i would do that as one piece i
wonder if a metal ball situation would
work
or voxel modeling
what's up alan how you doing
welcome to the stream
all right so how are we gonna what do we
wanna detail model
do we wanna det
so much detail down here i love the
detail
so cool
make a spring you can make a spring
pretty easily
what up steven straight from the react
video welcome
we're doing some 3d modeling together
we're going to we're trying to make this
this is the goal it's not going to
happen on this whole stream i promise
you that
but these are the main modules that
we're talking about
let's see what's good over here
so many dials and knobs oh my goodness
this is like eons of primitives just
primitives until you're dead
but i love it
i don't know maybe this little piece
this this like little connector piece
that'll be an easy one that we can start
with control
now let's keep it let's keep it in here
let's make a cylinder
we'll scale it down
scale it down until it's about the size
we want it
something like that and then we'll solo
it
and get up in there nice so this looks
to me like a six-sided situation so
we'll go six sides
and b and let's
yeah we're good i think we can
make three cuts yep
amazing
amazing all right i think this is a good
start
so let's hit
d and make it not d let's hit c
and make it editable and we're going to
turn this into this detailed piece right
here
beveled and all so the first thing
i will do we can so many different ways
to do this
select the middle piece here ul with the
loop selection
d for extrude and we can just bring it
on in
something like this
boom and we can make two cuts kl
let's find it yeah let's get up in here
we can make two cuts
um let's select this middle bit one
we'll give it two cuts select this
middle bit
bam we'll add a cut so we got two cuts
going along it
let's grab the line uh in line mode
we'll
grab those actually one at a time we'll
hit t
we'll push it up just like that
same deal for this one push it up
just like awesome
then from here we can actually take
these edges
these four edges on the top and bottom
and i just want to taper them
just a little bit technically
that can be a bevel so if we scale it
we don't want to scale it on the y so
let's uncheck why
just want to scale it in
something like something like that
and let's actually do this with uh maybe
a hundred mil
lens and we'll give
yeah no that that's nice that's nice
let's go up to the top here
we'll select all this all these polygons
and we're going to extrude enter that's
mw
actually in fact let's do it another way
let's
now we'll be fine we'll extrude enter
d for extrude push that up
mw extrude enter again we will bring
that
out to about there
extrude once more
and that should be
that and then
essentially what i did down there was
bevel everything so i'm gonna do that
here too so ul we'll select both of
those
m s is your bevel tool you can right
click and get all this stuff from here
but
gotta learn those those shortcuts um
subdivisions
zero and we'll just bevel it
something like that
so that's about as complex as like most
of these shapes get
um it's just beveling and extruding
let's get the bottom of this
mw and it looks like this one's tapered
it a lot more
d and it will extrude it just like that
now if you want you can do an extra
level of beveling
i like to i don't i don't like to bake
in my bevels
so what i'll do is select that cylinder
hold shift
and use a bevel modifier now this looks
like
garbage because you need to just drop
your offset so 0.02
and we can give it like three
subdivisions
and drop that to .01 even two
subdivisions perhaps
one subdivision maybe that's probably
all you need
that gives it an extra layer of
of bevelage and then as far as texturing
goes right you can see it here
looking nice it looks like it's some
sort of copper or bronze
so that's just going to be grayscale
gorilla
their tech products are killing it you
can just drop something similar on there
and maybe give it a cubic
a cubic projection boom
pilot way less so 0.1 0.1 or maybe i was
other way around 10 and 10. yep
and we're not going to see this so close
like this
it's definitely going to be from like
pretty darn far away
and maybe you can take your phone angle
and uncheck this turn it to like
20 or 10. yeah there you go that looks a
lot better
actually gonna be this for days
trying to get this look right you know i
was gonna go
this machine is going to be so cool when
it's done
i can't wait
that was that one piece that one piece
we have to do a lot more times
to get everything else
all right i'm just going to keep working
on it keep doing my thing
ah there we go
sometimes your ref does this thing where
it's
the mouse gets all sticky
i gotta switch over like that so
apologies
all right there's another little like
cable piece down there we can make that
so see what we can do grab the cylinder
hold ctrl make a cube right on it scale
it down
crunch it down thickness is not too much
there
the ball will probably be a section here
where the ball is going to roll over
this thing
and i can't wait to texture everything
get the edges looking all nice
maybe we'll take this piece to the
completion
all right so it's looking like i can see
the underside of this and
to me this looks like
it's like a hollow hollow piece and make
this editable
grab the bottom mw extrude enter
and then d push it up
all right so we have this like metal
tray
but inside are
some welded pieces of metal so that
looks to me
like a
that could be a tube
with oh but i need to spawn it on this
so we select
this cube hold ctrl make the tube scale
it down with t
we want to orient it plus
z yeah sure we can give it
zero height segments and
only four rotational segments
and we'll rotate it 45 degrees
and let's go ahead and bring this
down in something like this
we'll hit c on it make it editable
and let's move these points around so
let's grab these points
so this is a good example of local and
world orientation so this is local
orientation
i hit w and it switches to world
orientation because we want to just
bring this along
these axes here same deal well
technically
no we got to do this way
bring this over here
and again there's probably faster ways
to do this
there's always a faster way
that's what it looks like to me um let's
go ahead and make a loop selection on it
ul loop selection w
bam
and if you want you can scale this in
a bit
that's what that piece is looking like
to me
um there's some sort of support bar in
the back it's held up by a support bar
that is connected to
the back of this box so
let's grab this we'll put tube inside
the cube
bam
hit it against that back wall and drop
it down
something like that take the cylinder we
can put the
cloner in the cylinder as well as the
random
modifier and we'll just move this
against the back wall and this will
probably move the ball along this or
something
raj yo welcome welcome
i know building mechanical objects can
be so tiring says
scotty t boy imagine building a space
rocket or hovercraft
wiring compulsory oh my goodness i think
the final result will be incredible but
it's just this like tedious
effort required to getting it to look
like really
truly incredible all right let's bevel
this thing
with a bevel modifier we don't want to
bake them in
so we're going to use the bevel modifier
holding shift
we'll drop that bevel modifier in and
let's drop the amount to 0.01 it's a
little small
0.03 what does 0.1 look like
a little too much 0.05
yeah a little bit of bevel it's going to
catch the light really nicely
when will the final result come neutral
my final result or all the montages
well i'll give you the answer for
everything so
schedule wise this is the last live
stream
for the alternate realities challenge
um it doesn't mean it's what kind of is
the
last week because july 31st is
my birthday but it's also a day where
i'm posting
a pre-edited video so i can enjoy my
birthday
uh i'm gonna teach you guys how to make
a concrete texture pack
we're gonna go outside take a bunch of
photos of concrete stitch them together
in photoshop
process them and make normal maps uh
specular
diffusion roughness maps we're gonna
make all the maps
that it takes to create a texture i'm
going to show you how to do all that
and at the end of that video i'm going
to be releasing
that concrete texture pack it's going to
be called right now the current name is
endless concrete because
my goal was to take photos of massive
slabs of concrete that you don't find
online
and capture them process them and make a
pack out of them
so that will be available next week for
you guys would be pretty affordable
and i'll have 50 off for the first week
as usual for all my stuff
um if you're on the patreon it'll come
with it the patreon is coming in two
weeks
so back to the schedule july 31st
endless concrete texture tutorial
um we have uh what else
the seventh will be the patreon
announcement
that's when i'm announcing the patreon
we'll do a big live stream have a good
time i'll give out some free patreon
stuff and
um maybe play some mario kart maybe play
some smash bros maybe do some modeling i
i don't know we'll have fun with it i'm
still figuring it out
the 14th is when i'm going to announce
the winners of this dynamic challenge
dynamic machines challenge a lot of you
said take an extra week to like
really look at the winners and
everything i'm gonna do that i'm gonna
take the extra week
i'll take two weeks for it and then i'll
announce the top 100
along with the top five winners
on the live stream the following week
will be
i believe that's the 21st the following
week august 21st
i think that's it on saturday uh will be
the
top 100 montage that's when you'll see
everything together
and then the week after will be the uh
the all renders montage so it's going to
be a awesome week
in august so i look forward to it i got
to get this thing done in a week's time
huh
better get back to work
all right knocking it out
oh
so let's texture this thing
let's texture this thing
i'll solo this with the octane sky
and the box bam
and for the sake of actually viewing
this i'm going to switch my
legs
i want this to look as real as possible
so
based off the reference um it's like a
dark gray
metal that's scratched on the corners
and the edges let's do it from scratch
i'll make a glossy material no i'll make
a metal material
let's drop that on this cube
and let's give it a lot of roughness 0.5
maybe let's take
the
specular down a little bit we want that
roughness really
really cranked so 0.1 on the roughness
there
let's see
and let's give this thing
we want to do let's give this a general
bump texture across everything so i'm
going to do this with octane noise
it's been a minute since i've textured
on the stream let's grab some octane
noise we'll pipe it into the bump
and i'm gonna set this uh projection up
correctly so projection let's make a
projection node and
always on noise it's xyz to uvw
i'll show you the difference so anytime
i deal with noise i always crank the
contrast to 100
so i can see what's going on i always
change the projection
xyz to uvw transform node let's bust
that out
and let's scale it down smaller
0.05 i'll show you what this projection
situation does so if i were to zoom up
in here
you see how the noise pattern continues
or should continue over the edge
let me give this a little bit more bevel
0.05
that looks better yeah you see how the
the
the noise actually continues over the
edge
but if i set this to box
the projection you can see how like it
doesn't actually continue
it's clipped off
you can see a seam there but if you
change to xyz to uvw
it continues around the edge continues
around the corner
and that's what we want for best results
so we want to give this metal a little
bit of bump so what we'll do is mess
with our transform
0.01 we want to keep it very small
the contrast is ridiculous if we set it
to zero
it's still too much we want
this to be very subtle let's change the
pipe to turbulence maybe circular or
chips i like turbulence
and i think default is fine we just need
to tone it down so
to tone this down we've toned it down as
much as we can right
we've taken the contrast to zero i guess
we can take the gamma to like point one
or two but no that's not going to do
what we want
so here's what i'll do i will make a
multiply node between the noise and the
bump right
and then i'm going to give it a float
node and the float is just a number
and the number is going to be our
intensity
so if this is at zero there's no bump
and if it's at 20
it's like ridiculous which happens to
look the same as one
so it's zero or one and anywhere in
between
i'll keep it subtle
yeah 0.01
and i can maybe take the scale of this
down a little bit more
and we can go 0.005
0.008 maybe
purlin might be a little bit better for
us we can take it to 0.01
0.015
and maybe scale it up just a bit 0.008
so it's super subtle and we can adjust
that bump
um depending on what it looks like in
our camera if it looks like just a
normal solid
in our camera then we can scale up that
bump
i actually have a video uh the thumbnail
is like a pen and a knife
and i talk about scaling up your
detail to match where your camera is at
technically it might not be accurate to
the
object itself but based on the camera
it'll look it'll look real
uh one second hold on
all right the house alarm almost went
off
that's a close one all right
so next what we want to do is give this
thing some scratches
and some fingerprints perhaps and that's
going to be in the roughness channel so
let's go into this material
and let's give this thing some
fingerprints first so i'll make an image
texture
and i want to find this little preview a
little sneak peek onto that
concrete pack huh um
just to let you know one of these images
it's called endless concrete right the
source file is 196
000 pixels by like
8 000 pixels tall it just goes
alright it's gonna be incredible i can't
wait for you guys to get your hands on
it
um let's see okay so we want to find my
surface imperfection pack
vfx materials textures
surface imperfections volume one we
don't need
4k files for this 2k
maybe but we're probably good with 1k
imperfections on this so i'm gonna grab
smudged monitor is probably a good one
got some nice wipes on it and stuff
and let's invert it
and let's adjust the gamma to open it up
just a little bit
and let's do the same deal we want to
give projection
transform and projection for this
i believe is box
and transform looks like it needs to
come down
so we just get some nice fingerprint
smudges on this thing
give it a little bit of
a little bit of extra detail
that's so close it's so tiny
right that looks really nice we can
probably take that down
just a little bit so we can do that
float situation again or just power
so power if we zero it out okay we don't
want
that we can actually do this with a
gradient node
so let's find octane gradient
drop it in and instead of black being
black what if black was white
okay so that means
it's as if we didn't put any image
texture on it there's no surface
imperfection
if we go white if we go black it's full
on
that means and we're gray is right in
the middle
so we just dial it down as much as we
need keep it subtle
we don't want it to look like scratches
because they aren't scratches yet
or you know we could switch it out for a
different imperfection so let's grab
like
i don't know another one of these
smudged
monitor images here let's bring that
back up to black see what it looks like
in full
it actually looks a little bit better a
little less like uh
like scratches
but this is gonna be so subtle
so you don't need to go too crazy with
it we can take the transform
and just scale it around and find the
in the right spot that we want on this
that's fine yeah it looks good to me
now let's give this some
scratches on the edges
or no let's give it scratches all over
the whole thing
very subtle very subtle so we're gonna
do that in
we could do that a few different ways we
can make a mixed material but i would
like to keep things into one material
for now
so what i'll do is
based on the reference the scratches are
a lighter gray
and i'm wondering where that lighter
gray can come from you know it can come
from maybe it's the specular
yeah i think it'll be the specular
so here's what we'll do let's make an
image texture for specular
and let's select one of the scratch
imperfections i have and if you guys
want to grab these assets i have them on
my gumroad
down below link in the description
let's grab this like subtle subtle
scratches here
and it looks like we need to cool this
out just a bit
so what we'll do first let's apply
the box projection to this
texture and then we need to transform it
down
it's gonna be too large point one
looks about right and we can
move this around so it fits everything
nice and easy
awesome and we can bring the gamma
in or up to like
choke down those scratches or
we can bring the gamma up to have more
scratches
shine through but what we want to do
regardless of where the scratch level is
at we actually want to give it an
octane gradient to control the black and
white
values right so
it looked a little something like this
with the scratches
yep that feels about right to me a
lighter gray
and let's try switching it out for a
different one
these are really intense
too intense way too intense maybe the
original one was fine
fiber maybe we could use fiber
this is like dust and stuff
i feel like that first one is the one we
need
alternatively we can go to grayscale
gorilla plus library
textures and they have some scratches
that might work for us
let's see what chad ashley's got scratch
o2
drop that in there give it the
projection and transform nodes
little intense pretty intense
yeah i think i like mine a little bit
better right now they have a lot of
different ones but
let's do that and let's
adjust it so the scratches are a little
bit more
subtle
super subtle
just a sliver then we can open that up a
little bit more
show a bit more of the scratches i want
to make sure that bump is still there
yep looking good
and now we want to scratch the edges
because in the reference it actually has
scratched edges right so
we want to get up in there let's double
click this
and the way we're going to do that is
with a
dirt node in the specular channel
so here's what we'll do let's get rid of
the specular channel and let's start
from scratch
actually i want to match that original
color we had i like that original color
a lot better
cool so i'm going to save my stuff
shame on me for not having a v2 by now
cool and let's do
a dirt node in the specular channel so
let's type in dirt
and what this is going to do is
essentially make a mask for us
and this mask if i right click and solo
it you can hopefully see what's going on
strength will crank to 10 radius
0.1 invert it
and there you go those are your edge
scratches
we can take the radius to 0.3
point five perhaps one centimeter
five centimeters one centimeter
gonna mess with these settings
until this feels right let's see radius
0.2
0.1
strength tolerance whereas the spread is
at 1 distribution
one details uh
let's see what this looks like if we
unsolo it
so it looks like what we have
here we want to invert this
and we want to grow that that mask
but why is it being a butt right
we want to go point three there we go
so we have this limited to the edges
but i'm unsure as to why
the selection isn't growing
i'm just messing with this
trying to get it to do what i wanted to
do
sean the challenge has begun this is the
last week of the challenge
you can find out more by clicking the
link below in the description
which leads to the announcement video
goodness what happened
seems like to invert it
i don't know why the radius is is doing
what it's doing here
sometimes things are glitchy you know
we want to invert this invert it
and it's kind of doing what we wanted to
do
but not really
there's a bummer i don't know why this
is not working
because if i were to test this on
a cube very large cube
and we were to throw that dirt node on
here
we solo it 100 strength
radius uh
one foot
why is that not working we invert it
okay so the inversion works
and it seems to be working on a large
object
that's exactly what we want so that's on
the corners of everything
maybe it's just so small
but it should grow like that you see how
it grows
so if we know it's working here
then on this guy
we need to take the radius down
and we'll solo it
it's weird it's like it's only working
past
i guess that's what we gotta gotta work
with huh
anyway
those are our edges we have our edges
selected but what we want to do
is chip the edges and scratch the edges
just on specific parts
so this needs a gradient
map here let's throw that on there and
let's actually invert this so i'll flip
these up
these points around so only
the edges are shiny
versus the actual normal material for
this thing
and then from here
we want to chip away at that and just
have it be on
like the corners essentially so what
we'll do
is grab a noise node
we'll pipe that into the specular
and once again we'll give the contrast a
hundred
projection will be set to xyz to uvw
transform node and we'll scale it down
these are our like chip little scratch
pieces
and let's adjust this maybe we'll do
a we'll do like 10 octaves
and the omega we can set to 1. so it's
really fine detail
maybe it's maybe it's 0.9
on the omega and we bring the gamma
all the way up so there's just tiny
little bits on the edges
and what we'll do is essentially combine
this with this gradient
and i believe that will be it's either
through an add or a multiply
let's grab the multiply put that on
there okay so it's not the multiply it's
probably an add grab the add
type that in
hmm
need to invert this
like this needs to be
at hundred percent
then we want to let's see
we need an invert as well
radiant octane gradient we'll flip it
and then we'll try multiplying these two
together
and get very confusing even for myself
sometimes
okay that's kind of what we want we're
kind of getting there
you can see how it's taking away some of
the chips
so what we want to do if we invert this
yep it's just chipping certain parts of
it
but it's none of it has
any specular to it so maybe
what we do is take this black level and
bring it up to a dark gray
nope that needs to say fully black this
chip piece
maybe everything at the end needs a
gradient
and this is what determines the overall
reflectivity
yep here we go of everything
my goodness that took a minute then
we can mess with this octane noise node
to decide how chipped this thing is
and then we can open up the radius on
the dirt map
so instead of 0.06 we can just do 0.1
and it'll open it up a little bit more
0.2
that opens it up too much
0.1 is plenty we can take this let's see
let's take this noise and give it
more omega 1.8
we can take the gamma down so it's a bit
more scratched all around
and then just kind of walk it in
until you find the right look
that's a scratched scratched edge there
on that metal piece and we can keep
going
with more detail and more detail
you know that's that's the manual way if
you want to do it like
the grayscale gorilla bridge or not the
grayscale gorilla the qixel mega scans
bridgeway let's try
that
let's hit up surfaces
let's go to
where are you metal bam
we want treated
disposable aluminum magazine
that's pretty sweet let's download this
we can probably just do a 2k
resolution we'll export that
up in our scene let's drag and drop it
onto this piece here
and we need to
make sure it's oriented properly so it
looks like we have a normal
gloss specular albedo
i want to take all of these and give
them a projection node
the quickest way to do that
is organize all this stuff for a second
awesome
so we can select all these right click
go to add selected
projection and let's set it to box
and transform it down 0.1
it's very similar it's very similar
we can go to the albedo and mess with
the
gamma perhaps
maybe take the contrast up
something like that maybe it's got some
scratches built into it
um we could also mess with the way this
is being uh interpreted here so the
material type universal we can set it to
glossy octane
see if that changes things to look nicer
for us but i think universal looks a
little bit more metallic
ggx model or a beckman model
there's just different ways that the
program
interprets like specular and metal and
stuff
all right
and we could probably scale this up a
little bit more
so texture projection let's take it to
1.5 maybe
oh no actually we want to do that in the
transform
0.2 double the size
you know so you can mess with it figure
out any sort of texture you want it
might be a little too scratched for what
we're doing i think so
so maybe we just scrub to a different
part of the model that's less scratched
go to the albedo or
texture or the transform node
specifically and just
transform it along
the if
maybe we make it less contrasty
so we just hit with one
something like that perhaps
what happened to our tube oh i guess
because we're in solo mode
this can be a process is going to be a
process
18 uh 1080 by 1920 is the resolution for
this
block that ratio
alt v bring up our hud or our uh safe
frames
turn them on there and if this is you
can't check the safe frames box just
click this
the viewer up here click this little
border on the window
we can see what this is looking like
as we scrub through here we can lock it
0.3
and you can see what i mean like all
that work we put in to
this piece and you can barely tell that
it's scratched you can barely tell the
detail
that we added to that so you have to be
very careful
when adding a bunch of detail spending a
lot of time on
on a piece it may not be worth it
um so i would really suggest you know
you model out your thing
as broadly as possible you build your
scene as broadly as possible and then
slowly add in detail slowly add in
detail
there was a really cool video someone
put out of their process their dynamic
machines process
and it was of like a frog machine like a
frog
city and there was a giant frog statue
i don't have the link to it but if you
guys know i'm talking about like
maybe one of the mods can can drop it in
here
um but it was a really cool breakdown
they did it in a really cool way and i
think
they basically showed the process where
they worked their machine first they did
their dynamics first
and then they worked in the detail and
they worked in more detail more detail
over time they didn't start with a
little detail you don't start
with a pencil and you get in there and
you start doing like the detail of the
eye and then you build out from there
you know you start with a sketch you
start with a very general sketch so
i would highly encourage you all to
focus on the broad strokes first
make sure your scene functions and then
go in for the detail
but that's i'm just giving you an
example of like how detailed it can get
on this and how detailed that
it might get when i'm doing this so
at the end of the day it's an
educational stream you know trying to
try and learn some stuff
joneslab what's up thank you for the
super chat i will stay hydrated thank
you so much
got some water for you right here
what else we got really sticks thank you
for the super chat
much appreciated a long time fan was
wondering if you have an
all-time favorite quarter crew video
man yeah the lion king video was amazing
getting set on fire was amazing
what else the who shot the tv thing was
hilarious
the jury where uh nico
got put on trial for having a dirty
equipment room
might be one of my favorite ones of all
time
uh the mario kart one where carmichael
like snaps his neck
super hard i i i'm in tears every time
there's so many good episodes
so uh yeah man thanks for the super chat
thanks for bringing me back
good stuff good time there's a lot
the the node video we did actually
playing frogger where each person had a
different button
was the best i love that
one what kind of water do i drink ben
shout outs
um h2o man just straight up h2o
classic
all right i'm keep going
thanks for hopping in with me y'all
we got 600 people up in here doing it
big
i keep doing this i keep bringing this
up
what can we do in the last hour what do
we want to do in the last hour here
[Music]
how do we want to spend our time i can
just keep detailing out
different mechanical pieces we don't
worry about texturing too much
so i'm actually going to switch back
over
and bring up the chat
how are y'all doing you guys having a
good time
give me a thumbs up if you guys are
having a good time
probably got got another hour on this
um do a bit more detail modeling to keep
building this thing out
because it's got to be done at some
point you know
spoofers thank you for the super chat
what is jan and wes
up to these days i may have missed a
video talking about it but i miss him
all right so jan i actually hang out
with jan every single week we go rock
climbing together
um he's not joining me after the stream
but
uh every single week we go top roping
together outdoors with ropes he taught
me how to anchor
up safely so he's doing good he's on a
shoot right now
um and wes i hadn't talked with wes in a
minute but
last i heard wes uh just wrapped a movie
yeah he did some cool stuff with dave
storm and some other uh like
um people who were on vine at the time
so he's doing cool stuff i love wes he's
a super positive guy
always he's always telling me to sit up
straight you know he's like keep your
back
straight man like you know what you're
right dude
right gotta love wes he's one of my
favorites
uh professor yes start at 113 dynamics
are turned on at frame 113 absolutely
unless we got any questions from y'all
questions from y'all
[Music]
ah the mic cuts out a little the gate is
a little too high hey shout outs let me
see if i can fix that real quick for you
hmm yes cam
no let's go to my camera this is boring
stuff but it's got to be done
and filters that gate
i think that's better that should be
better
that should be better what i have for
lunch i didn't have lunch yet
and i probably got some chicken in the
fridge did i go to college i kind of
went to college i did like a technical
school for a year and a half
but ended up dropping out um
i've told that story a couple times so
basically
i went to a tech school they're teaching
photoshop they're teaching after effects
they're teaching a little bit of cinema
4d they're teaching how to draw
that kind of stuff and at the time
i knew everything they were teaching in
the after effects class because
i watched all the video co-pilot andrew
kramer tutorials and i was on it
that was like that was prime time for me
for video copilot after effects
tutorials so i happen to know everything
in the after effects class
and you know there's a photoshop class
too
it was a rough class um there was an
illustrator class it was an okay
it was a okay class but like i knew most
of the stuff i knew c4d i knew after
effects i knew
um it was not illustrator i knew
photoshop
so the classes were quite boring and the
one teacher i had
who was amazing mr mason
he actually allowed me to work on my
youtube videos
way back uh this is probably 2010.
he allowed me to work on my youtube
videos as a grade because he was like
dude you know after effects
like have fun do your thing
and you know it was a rough process for
me i didn't really enjoy it just because
i
i wasn't learning i wanted to learn more
but i'd already learned as much as
possible just by you know being online
they were beginner classes right they
didn't offer the advanced stuff
so um
from there freddie asked me
i was living in georgia at the time in
atlanta and freddie
who you know ran the freddie w channel
he did the rocket jump stuff
we were fans of each other and he was
like yo um you should move out here
because i had visited prior i had
visited him i met sam and nico i met
freddie and brandon i met jimmy and like
everybody out here
i was like man i would love to but i
don't think i mean i'll ask my dad
i asked my dad and he said no you got to
get your degree
so i was like okay all right
and um i went to my after effects
teacher and i told him about the
opportunity i was like look
like my dad wants me to get my degree
what do you think
and he said if you have a job in la the
only reason we're going to school here
is to get a job in la
and if you have that offer before you
have your degree then i would go for it
you could always come back to school
later
i told it to my dad and he was like
go for it all right sounds good to me i
was like wow i wasn't expecting
you to say that i packed up all my stuff
and like drove across country
and i moved in with freddie in this back
room
corridor is in studio
studio three and studio four dress level
zero
is in studio five and six and i moved
into studio six
in the back room without any windows it
was brick walls all around
i had to put in carpet um
and that was the best it was really the
best because i got to work with like
people i really respected
looked up to and that i could learn from
i got into it you know
dove into it and learn through doing
just filming doing vfx uh doing vfx for
freddy uh doing you know i was working
on carbon warfare 2 at the time
so it was just a lot of learning and
surrounding myself with a lot of people
that
did what i wanted to do and
you know that's kind of the great thing
about the internet is that you can find
a community of people who love doing
what you love doing
the more you can surround yourself with
people that push you and surround
yourself with people that
inspire you then you're going to be in a
better place
so if like you're really into rock
climbing
you want to hang out with some rock
climbers who are a lot better than you
or if you really want to learn 3d
you want to hang out with 3d artists who
are better than you so
i'm constantly trying to look and learn
as much as possible
i don't have all the answers on the
channel like if i can teach a thing or
two that's great
but really if i can inspire you to you
know open up a 3d program and start
messing with some stuff then that's even
better you know
um so long question or long answer
for a short question did i go to college
i did yeah i did
but it ended up just not being right for
me
at the specific tech school i was at i
didn't go to film school as a tech
school
um so
yeah um what's the discount code for
concierge there is no discount code you
just
if you spend 10 bucks they'll give you
an extra 10 bucks that's how it works
you can verify your phone number two for
an extra five bucks so if you spend
10 bucks you can get an extra 15 bucks
towards your render and that'll give you
plenty of render credits to render
anything you want um in this case the
dynamic machines challenge hopefully
a lot of y'all are working on them and
getting to the point where we're coming
down it's about a week left
and hopefully you guys have some
submissions to start rendering and if
you want to use a render farm
concierge render they got a good deal
for it for you all so
yeah there's no promo code it's just if
you spend 10 bucks they will match that
and you'll they'll give you another 10
bucks on top of that
but yeah um let's see what we can wrap
out here
on our submission
right
hmm what's the best way
and our time spencer thank you for the
super chat i appreciate you
you say do you have any tips for
organizing these community art contests
every time i tried it never really seems
to gain traction
thanks for all you do organ how to start
them
um well it will it helps to have a
youtube channel with people on it
and it helps to have a discord with
people on it but here's the thing i
didn't have a discord with people on it
a year and a few months ago i started it
about a year and a few months ago
and it went from zero people to i think
now it's at like 32 or 33 000 people
um so
really it's consistency stay consistent
with what you do
and you will grow if you stay consistent
the only way i was able to start a
community challenge like this is by
having
an audience of people you can also reach
out to people
say hey i would love for you to
participate in this challenge i want to
put together an end product and i think
it's going to be cool
and like the more you do it the fact
that you show that you've done it people
be like oh yeah that's cool
the second one did a lot better than the
first one because people saw the first
one
hopefully the third one this one here
will do better than the second one
because more people saw the second
one and it just builds you know you just
gotta stay consistent with it
and it we're all gonna grow slowly no
one's going to
blast off i've been doing youtube since
2006.
that is that's a long time that's almost
like
math that's like 15 years
that's a long time so it doesn't happen
like that
you just need to stay consistent with it
all right let's see
what do we want to do here
uh and ronan do you know if uh the
concierge bonus applies to people who
are already members um
it says for new or new
uh signups so maybe you just want to
you know switch your email sign up
and you can get it that way that's what
i do that's what i would do
all right
how do we want to spend our last
45 minutes here together
all right let's build some pipes or
something
build some pipe pieces
nice thin pipe
right it looks like there's these pipe
clamps and stuff
i wonder if mcmaster carr has
any pieces we can bring over
let's do a little search
so they have hose and tube clamps
um
cable ties i think
hose and tube clamps will probably be
what we need
now the question is just do they have
um they actually have
cad files for these they do oh my
goodness
yes let's download this
and let's start organizing this stuff
because organization's the only way
you're going to get through a
complex scene so art vfx
um or you know what yeah i'll save them
here
models
mick master car
bam
hold shift drag it into the scene that
way
you don't have to bring it into a new uh
a new scene every single time
we're gonna grab all these pieces that
make up this clamp
we'll right click connect objects plus
delete
hit s to snap us to the actual piece
and we can just scale this to
you know each individual pipe
now to get it fully synced up and lined
up with this tube i'm going to use the
transfer tool
so you can hit shift c and type in
transfer
bam right up in here and i've docked it
it should be up in here
i really not what's going on
uh let's see let's see why strange
bring this card up
layout back okay so the transfer tool i
got it docked up here
custom button almost select i hit the
transfer tool and just select
the cylinder and hopefully it should
sync it up yep just perfectly and then i
can rotate things
and i know if i scale it down it's just
going to perfectly clamp with it
and let's make sure we select the y
boom
awesome
something funky happened with this screw
though
let me go back
until we baked it down let's take a look
at it see what it looks like before we
did the bake and it actually came in
janky came in like that so maybe there's
another one we can use
there's so many of these it's crazy
like this this cable tie is pretty sweet
this metal one try and grab this let's
download it
bam
and drop it into our scene let's delete
this one
shift drag drop it right in
and it looks like this is that looks
that looks proper
that's a tiny one but we can definitely
use
it
i wonder if someone online has like
got all these fbxes and have them in one
project file because that'd be super
helpful
let's connect objects plus delete and
hit the transfer tool once more
get it lined up with this cylinder
and we can hold shift bam
scale it down just a bit
we got this super detailed like piece
here
super cool
so much detail with like no effort i
love it
god keeps keeps happening keeps
happening
but what about topology nah
it looks good in the render that's good
enough for me
um let's keep going down this pipe and
seeing what little clamps we can find
like there's these uh
these square clamps that hold the pipe
together or hold some sort of like
wires down to the pipe and it looks like
this pipe has a lot of
clamps on it and that square
bracket piece
let me show you guys how to cut a circle
out of a square
it's a good tip to know so let's do
a plane i'll hold that uh hold ctrl i'll
make a polygon rather
right there we'll scale it down and
let's go ahead and solo it and i'll show
you guys how to do this so if i were to
apply
a subdivision surface to this
polygon it'll turn it into a basically a
circle
but let's go ahead and bake this down
hit c
and q will toggle this on and off right
and what you want to do is
actually i think the best way to go
about this is probably drop a plane in
here
because we want some slices up in this
b see what we're working with and i
think let's try five and five
we can do there uh four and four maybe
yep four and four will work for us
and what we wanna do is make that
editable by hitting c
let's cut a hole right up in here
just delete that
and see what it looks like okay giving
us a square
but what if we want to make this a
circle so i'm going to grab
these corners and essentially turn it
into a
like diamond that is a circle
so that's a circle out of a square and
we can tighten it up
kl make some cuts along here make some
cuts
make some cuts
boom boom
and that's clean super clean
and you can take that
control a
hit d for extrude bring this up just a
little bit bring it up a lot and then
bring it up just a little bit more
that will be essentially
bam a perfect little piece here
that if we bring things back we can
scale
this plane down
and essentially make this little module
that holds this pipe
in place and we can grab a couple more
screws from mcmaster
to get this little piece right here
right and if you want that indentation
it looks like there's a little
indentation in there
you can just come up in here
and let's do
these pieces
and we can hit d
push them back and probably scale them
down see
this like this
and that's a little extreme it feels a
little extreme
we need to save some room
for the actual screws so i'll grab this
just push that in
or even crunch it down just a little bit
and then push it in
or we can go kl bam make that
selection grab these points one and two
push them out just a little bit
like so then we push this back
we can take this top piece
bring it down just a little bit
we want to select all of them
point mode bam just that right there
bring it down
these ones here up just a little bit
one and two
something like that
we might be able to tighten this up if
we
make a cut here and here
something like that yeah it feels pretty
good then you put those
screws on the left and right
nice very nice
maybe we grab this and just scale it in
a little bit
and let's grab some
want to make a screw we wanted to make a
screw
ourselves
i mean it could be very simple you could
just do
something like
hold control let's make a
cylinder
hit t we'll scale it down
holding shift will snap 90 degrees scale
it down more
bring it over to the side
yikes make it skinny
awesome this probably doesn't need this
probably like six-sided
something like that
and we can give it uh we'll just make it
editable
let's actually now let's let's crunch it
down
it's just the head of this thing grab
all these bits
kl boom just like that
loop selection ul d for extrude and
that's
really all it needs hold shift
now we can bake the bevel in this is
small enough
let's take this whole thing
let's select all of these cuts here
maybe except for this one and hit m n
that's going to
remove those bits maybe i'll do this one
too
yep grab the back piece
move it up
mw extrude enter
and d for extrude we're not going to see
that piece
and let's bake in the bevel
so ul loop selection grab all these
all these bits here if you're clipping
like this you can hold
ctrl d or press ctrl d and change your
view clipping to
tiny
all of that i'm gonna hit m s three
subdivisions
goodness okay and we'll just we'll just
type it in
0.01 this is 0.005 this is tiny
there we go
we could probably do let's see i'll just
use a bevel modifier
hold shift drop the bevel modifier in
there 0.005
three subdivisions that looks
pretty good maybe one drop the phone
20.
and maybe we take it back up to 40.
good and i'm definitely going to make
iterations of all this stuff versus
full-on copies
and you know what i think i'm gonna
adjust this a little bit
so this comes out
a lot more
awesome
our hex screw
and i'm gonna make it iteration
for an instance boom hex screw instance
and we'll
drag it over right here
don't forget to randomly rotate these
things
any details very tiny details
for modeling it's gonna have to pay off
here it's all in the
all in the details for modeling tiny
little bits
this is going gonna be crazy wow okay
going back to the reference what else do
we see we see
some valves and stuff with some like
readouts and whatnot
lots of stickers we can add those later
and zip tie bits
let's do a quick little zip tie
situation um
so for the zip tie let's do
be the best way
to adjust a zip tie well i guess
having different size zip ties i don't
think master car has some but i don't
think they have the
cad files for it so zip ties should be
pretty
darn simple um
that's going to be a a tube
punch this down
and we match this up
very skinny zip tie
and let's go 32 segments on it
we can keep this ring complete
let's give it a fill it
with one segment
at 0.002 0.005
just a little bit there and maybe we go
50 segments on that
i think it'll be too tiny to see any
rivets so we don't worry about that for
now
but what we will see is
essentially the little like cap piece
so i'm gonna scale this down until it's
just snug on this
grab this cylinder we'll set it to
give it a couple more rotational
segments
grab the tube hold ctrl make a cube
scale it down
actually this would be more of a tube
situation
or even we can do this with a plane we
can do this so many different ways um
let's do it with a tube scale it down
let's give it four segments
rotate it 45 degrees on the correct axis
all right what's up everybody hopping in
from corridor
thanks for joining me thanks for hopping
over to the stream we're making some
cool stuff we're making
this it's i'm not gonna finish it on the
stream
but it's gonna work it's gonna be what
i'm working on over the next week for my
dynamic machines
submission which is my render challenge
to the 3d community we got a week left
if you want to join there's a link in
the description
uh pointing to the announcement video
it'll get you guys started
let's scale this tube down
and zip tie
zip tie
god dang it that happens this happens
all the time
all right so a zip tie
looks like it's coming in
um about make that
editable
all right all right rotate it 90 hold
and shift
we don't need all those segments either
we can get rid of those ul loop
selection
do this every time mn will dissolve them
and this little cube right here
is what the zip tie will be going into
so let's bring this up
and we'll scale it down
something like that very simple uh let's
go ahead
and
get rid of these bits too we don't need
those
m in and
crunch it down
like so awesome
grab that bevel modifier 0.005
and you probably need one last little
piece on this
so we'll make a cube here
holding ctrl to spawn it in place of
this thing
open it up just a bit
wrench it down
and this will be placed basically all
over this whole thing
no one's going to know bam that that
doesn't fit because it's going to be
tiny
take that cube
let's give it a little fill it that'll
fill it
boom one and we'll set that 2.05
let's open up this tube
just a bit
you take the phone down on that
bit more uniform
that's kind of our little zip tie piece
we don't need the extra geo here let's
set that to
one and this if we control
alt alt g that's going to be our zip tie
and we can essentially make an instance
of this
so there's no extra geometry being
calculated and we can move this up and
down
this this whole thing put them wherever
we want on any of these other tubes if
you want to get one on this tube over
here
you can hit the transfer tool bam pop it
over hit t
scale it up
oh why okay so scaling if i hit
c on that that'll turn it into its own
thing okay got you
scale it up ah okay so it's not we need
to adjust the gizmo so the gizmo
actually is
correct on the for real
one so let's find
our zip tie we'll go to a top view
hit l and we'll center this up
this gizmo up with the cylinder that way
it's being scaled from the middle
boom so now when we scale it up it's
it's actual actually proper
and then let's make a instance we can
move that over to this guy or just
again use the transfer tool so it's
right in the middle
and we can scale this up
i believe
this way 1.87
1.7
2.17 across the board or we can just
bake it down but yeah so you can
transfer these to different pipes
all across this whole thing
and there's different sized zip ties in
the world so
we have to worry about that maybe just
color them differently or something
and usually zip ties are wrapped around
pipes like this when there's
wires coming in through them so i'll
have to hook those up with a bunch of
wires and whatnot
give me a lot of work to get this done
what up wren we got ren in the chat
what's poppin yeah ren
so i'm building this out
and i'm attempting to like hand model
most of it
and then use like mcmaster car to
download cad models and stuff
to finish the rest of it but i want it
to look like this
it's going to be insane but it's a lot
of primitives
it's just a ton of primitives a lot of
wires
and uh some grungy textures
and the more complicated it looks i
think the better
so my goal is to populate this whole
thing
have it look like this and then figure
out a way for the ball to like
go through all this and turn this into a
contraption essentially
what's up wren good to hear from you
going to see your
your little thumbs typing away
oh man
everyone give a shout out to wren he's
holding it down
all right i'm about ready to wrap this
thing
up i'll probably make one more piece
one more detail piece on this thing
what do we want to do
hmm
it's just a lot of placing random little
objects
and this thing is so cool i don't know
what this is but it is awesome
yeah render hopefully god i called you
render
hopefully i can get my render to look
this good um
that's my goal that is 100 my goal
we'll see what i can do
thanks for popping in dude i'm gonna
build out one more piece here
see what we can do
oh this stepping system is really cool
that's awesome
oh it looks like there's like a i see
there's a
main server piece that's kind of built
out from this
everything is housed on this
extruded here that i see
if i can't find one of these little
dials on mcmaster
because i know they have them
where are you where are the dials
pressure gauge yes
there's no way they got the cad files
for this though
oh they do oh my goodness
okay
ah this website is the best all right so
let's get the
please specify presser gauge to download
psi one to one thousand
yes yes please all right
holding shift dragging into the scene so
you don't have to
copy it into a whole new scene
and if we take off the front face and
this
face and this face then there's nothing
inside but that's okay
we'll fill it with something later but
that's doing a lot for us
super cool i'll take this whole thing
select everything control
click connect objects plus delete
and let's select all these points
and we'll bake it down or not bake it
we'll optimize it you owe
so 3 900 points to 2 900 points
and that just again basically just
uh takes care of any points it merges
any points that are on top of each other
redundant points
so there's like a pressure gauge
attached to this thing
um this piece i feel like needs to be
optimized as well ctrl a 5700
hit uo for optimize 4200 amazing
amazing
i kind of want to thicken this piece up
a little bit too
let's take this whole thing
open it up just a bit there we go
bam bam goes up
awesome yeah red mcmaster cars the best
this all just comes down to the
materials at that point
uh ren i have no idea what this machine
is it's in a
book i have an art book of like
mechanical engineering
and it's from some sort of research
facility
in japan and i think it's like a
particle accelerator
facility or something like that um
that's all i know probably probably a
particle accelerator
or something
i have so much i have so much work to do
all right it looks like there's some
sort of like
main uh extruded bit here
this goes from top to bottom
just about like that
and behind all this is
behind all of this is like stuff
something like that
let's see what this looks like from this
view
don't be sweet i can't wait
can't wait this is gonna be filled with
so much detail
it's gonna be ridiculous
yeah the whole left side and the whole
right side is like sunk back
and all the detail is like right in the
center here and you have these pieces on
the left and the right
and there's these different platforms
here that's holding all these different
pieces
in place
yeah something like that
lots of pipes
ren what's up oh tomorrow's crew video
yes so tomorrow on corridor
uh ren essentially did
a submission for this
wait okay so he's saying it on and
honestly everyone who's here two weeks
ago
that smash game oh yeah the smash game
um but yeah tomorrow on corridor crew
ren did a submission for this challenge
and he's walking you through his entire
process
so i can't wait for y'all to see it it's
so good it's so good
so excited to see it it turned out so
well
minus the smash game
you guys will know what i mean minus the
smash game
just wait oh my goodness do you add
stuff to it
oh man i can't wait it's gonna be good
yeah ren had to like
had to like tweak it just to show that
he won
you had to rig it up you'll see what i
mean
you'll see what i mean
all right i think i think i'm going to
call it like i got obviously have a lot
of work to do
um we'll see how everything goes i'll
post my my progress in the discord
server
link below uh the submission link is
live if you're ready to submit your
render
click the link below it's a
submission.createwithclint.com
and follow it very carefully alright the
submission link follow it carefully make
sure you follow the rules
you can only upload a render one time
okay
um so make sure it's your final render
okay
um other than that yeah use concierge
render if you want to use a render farm
over this last week while everyone busts
out their renders
um they got you guys hooked up with a
nice deal and
what else yeah
order crew tomorrow ren's doing his
submission it's good stuff
um what does friend say actually there's
a very
there's very little about my process on
it
um that's all he said okay it'll be a
good video
regardless it'll be a good video and no
my hand is not always injured it's a
so many people ask this i just need to
pin this comment
to every live stream this is a glove so
i can
smoothly glide over my wacom tablet use
a tablet not a mouse
ah but with that y'all i think it's
about time
to call it i'll chill with y'all for the
next five minutes
i'll answer any questions you have
and uh and we're gonna call it
thanks for hanging with me everybody
thanks for sticking in
me a big month next month lots of sweet
videos coming out now it's in a patreon
first week of the month
dropping render montages announcing
winners it's gonna be sweet
it's gonna be a good one chris schmidt
oh my goodness yes i'm wrapping up
this is the time i'm wrapping up right
now oh my goodness
dude chris let me show you what i'm
trying to make let me show you this
it's like some sort of crazy electrical
engineering
thing i'm turning this into a
contraption that guides a ball from the
top to the bottom
as part of this dynamic machines
challenge and
you are the master of dynamics um i've
learned
i learned everything i know about
dynamics from mr
chris schmidt so it is an honor to have
you
here on the in the chat dude we still
got to do a stream together man
um hit me up on instagram or send me an
email or something let's do a stream
dude
uh so yeah i got a lot of work ahead of
me this next week chris i gotta build
this out and
make it look legit it's gonna be good
um any questions if you guys at me at
punisher i can see your questions a lot
easier but tai asks what tablet i
recommend or which i use
so i'm using the wacom intuos pro uh
four or five whichever one they're on
the newest one
it's great i use the medium sized one i
don't need a massive tablet
at my workstation the medium-sized one
is perfect it's got a bunch of shortcut
buttons on it
i gave some away or wacom gave some away
on my last challenge the alternate
realities challenge
they hooked you all up with some sweet
tablets so
i i recommend it it's very it's
reasonably priced
um and it's it's the way to go for sure
all right michael let's see um does it
have to be a machine
or is it allowed to do something else
well
it doesn't have to be a machine but
the the essence the soul of the
challenge it's called dynamic machines
right so
we want to essentially make a giant rube
goldberg contraption that guides the
ball
from the top to bottom so
you know people are doing very unique
stuff very creative stuff
i'm not gonna say it has to be a machine
but that's what i'm gonna be doing but
together it all works together as a rube
goldberg contraption
so just know that
i go by zach you are welcome for that
c4d uh
ad tip on mcmaster car it's a very good
one very useful site
do i sculpt i do not sculpt but if i had
to
you know using a pen tab would probably
be the way to go
killian yes i'm trying to make this a
guinness world record
um they take a long time to get back to
you
no news yet will i do more
views or videos with the corridor crew
absolutely
absolutely of course yeah those good
buddies over there
can we render in 1080 by 1920 times two
you mean
4k resolution but still like vertical
yeah you can
render it larger as long as your your
aspect ratio
is um 9 by 16 i believe
i think i said that right as long as
it's a vertical video you can
do a 4k version of it peace out wren
good to see you man have a good one
am i visiting the uk anytime i would
like to but not anytime soon
um thanks to everyone for you know for
joining me here on the stream it gets a
little difficult to talk
because i've been talking for the last
three hour how long i've been talking
for
three hours and 40 minutes you've been
talking straight so
words get jumbled towards the end but
that's how it is
um what else oh yeah i was saying
thanks for joining me everybody you guys
are great thanks for coming over from
corridor
if you are subscribed you aren't
subscribed by this point
hit that subscribe button if you want to
learn how to do
3d stuff if you want to join in on these
3d community challenges and if you want
to get
vfx tips and advice i'm dropping stuff
every single week so subscribe if you're
not subscribed already give me a thumbs
up
comment down below you know how it is on
what you want to see
next
any other good questions
i share a glove link i can't at this
moment but if you type in
tablet glove on amazon you will find
something
promise
hmm what else do we have any other good
questions here
um
don't do vfx but love watching this
stuff that's interesting very
interesting
uh quiz jam i'm glad you are entertained
um what else when can we turn in the
challenge you can turn it in
starting now but you have to august 1st
11 59 pm pst
if you submit after that this can't be
accepted in those submissions you know
can't be winning prizes delivering stuff
late no
the link is live right now submit the
links in the description
but y'all i think that's everything
uh i'm gonna bounce i'm gonna get some
rock climbing in i'm gonna eat some food
i'm gonna drink some water
uh it's been a good day thank you all
for
everything thanks for tuning in with me
and i'll see you next week i got a whole
video it's a pre-edited video coming for
you
my boy visual is doing the edit right
now
shout outs to visual helping with the
edit we're putting together
a video on how to go outside
shoot textures come back process them in
photoshop make normal maps
specular maps roughness maps and make
your own texture packs
and then i'm selling a concrete texture
pack it's called
endless concrete because these are not
just an ordinary concrete pack
these are the biggest concrete textures
you've ever seen
the internet doesn't even have them yet
they're going to have them next week
talking like massive walls of concrete
giant
under the bridge you know huge concrete
structures
and textures for you to use so
uh with that that's gonna be next week
50 off the pack for the first week when
it drops you know how it goes
i'll see you guys later it's been a
stream has been a string
peace out y'all good times
[Music]
and
[Music]
you